hello and welcome to this episode of the
future verse brought to you by
Intelligence Squared and wry I'm Harriet
Johnston and today we're delving into
the psychology of money and the
different ways we can move beyond our
learned behaviors to create lives of
Financial Freedom or at least some sort
of financial peace of mind at wrye our
mission is to help our clients build
lives in which wealth is defined by how
they live not what they own and that
means we're as interested in what our
clients want from their lives as we are
the numbers on their balance sheet so to
talk this through I'm joined by two very
experienced guests when it comes to
relationships and money and the
relationship between the two Lucy
barisford is a psychotherapist
broadcaster writer and former investment
banker for four years she hosted a sex
and relationships phone in show on which
she was dubbed The Naughty Mary Poppins
and she is currently the host of the
podcast on the couch which looks at
politics through the lens of psychology
Robin Powell began his career as a
journalist and founded a media
production company he now focuses
exclusively on financial content and is
the founding editor of the
evidence-based investor a Blog that
works to dispel the myths surrounding
investing and challenges the vested
interests of the asset management
industry Lucy you worked in investment
banking for 10 years before retraining
as a psychotherapist so what in inspired
that
transition uh quite a lot of pain I
think quite a lot of uh dissatisfaction
and and that is not to rubbish my 10
incredible years in Investment Banking
because I really did have a tremendous
time made friends for life and one of
whom is coming for lunch today so that
that shows you that it's it was a very
solid and healthy part of my life in
many ways but it wasn't completely
fulfilling and it's one of my missions
in life when I'm working clinically with
people is to really help people find
their voice really and I think I lost my
voice in Investment Banking I lost a
very big part of who I am and and and
what makes me feel fulfilled and but it
took a long time it took going into
therapy to make that shift and once I
had gone into therapy I remember
thinking yeah there there is something
missing and I need to dig a bit deeper
on this so uh I stepped away from the
investment banking life and all of the
amazing travel and all the amazing
people but I gained so much more in
terms of how my life changed and and the
purpose that I have now in life which is
great and and do you think there was
anything specifically about the
psychology of money that put you off or
had you change or maybe the lack of
conversation around the psychology of
money even though obviously in
Investment Banking it's kind of the
Focus right
well it it funny enough it ought not to
be the focus because it's a it's a
relational uh industry it it is about
money and it's about the flow of income
and it's about hopefully amplifying that
within the capitalist system but it is
also relationship Banking and what I
observed and what I was clearly much
better at than gazing at spreadsheets
which I literally probably even now
couldn't do was I was very good at
building relationships and I was very
good at at netw workking and and pulling
people together bringing people together
and in fact I I pivoted away during
Investment Banking away from the purely
transactional uh of you know m&a and and
IPOs to
actually augment and amplify the
relationships that the bank had and that
the clients had with themselves and I
suppose what I noticed was that if you
did that if you if you stepped away
purely from the the figures the numbers
the zeros at the end of the balance
sheet and you dug deeper into the
psychology of the people who were making
the widgets or um you know creating the
the wealth that actually the companies
thrived in a very different way and that
was maybe without realizing it my first
foray into the psychology of money that
it's that it's so much more than the the
actual cash it's about our attachment to
it and it's about our relationship to
issues around scarcity and emotional
Supply
and and that really is is what quite a
lot of my work is is
today Robin in your book you describe a
wakeup call you had about investing
while making an online documentary what
was your realization what mistakes had
you previously been making well I'd been
a a a a just a general television news
journalist for for for many years I had
no specialist expertise in in finance
for investing but I'd always been really
quite interested in it and I would read
the Sunday Times money section and uh uh
I'd read books uh and I really kind of
take an interest in in the stock market
and shares and so on but um you know
they say uh a little knowledge is a
dangerous thing and it certainly was in
my case because uh whatever I seem to do
uh you know whatever shares or funds or
set classes I I bought into they they
all tended to uh to flop um and I seem
to be doing all the right
things following the advice of you know
people who appeared to be experts and so
on and then um when I set up my own
production company about 12 years ago uh
our first client was a wealth management
firm who very much into um index funds
and passive investing and I was very
skeptical about this um and and uh I
said right okay I'll do it but I must
say you know I'm not sure about this
kind of passive investing business so I
I went to the US and interviewed some
very key people Jack Bogel the founder
of Vanguard which is a um very
successful wealth management firm asset
management firm out there um I spoke to
a couple of Nobel prizewinning
economists uh Eugene farmer uh and and
William sharp and and some really key
people in in the financial industry and
what amazed me uh uh har was was how
much information there is out there on
how to invest and yet not only do most
of us do almost the complete opposite of
what we should be doing we we're
actively encouraged by many Financial
professionals including sadly many
financial advisers to do the wrong
things um and yeah I'll perhaps talk in
a moment about how people should be
investing but but yeah I I I learned
that
I whatever I'd learned in the past was
was not doing me any favors so Robin
what are those those simple rules of
investing that it's possible to distill
your biren your philosophy down to where
where have you landed in the end well
there are six key um messages uh rules
if you like that that we um that we give
to readers in in the book and and the
first
one it should be obvious but actually a
lot of us make this mistake we we we
Pile in and we we buy things maybe act
on um tips in the newspaper and so on
whereas we really should be starting
with a purpose you know work out why are
we investing in the first place you know
and then to have a plan a broader
financial plan and then have a method so
that's the first rule the second thing
is just take a slice of everyone's
business don't worry about which shares
or which funds you should be buying just
buy the whole thing you know don't look
for the needle just buy the Hy stack and
you can do that so easily now with a
with a broadly Diversified Global uh
Equity Index Fund
um to dilute your risk because you know
investing inevitably involves risk you
basically add lots of time um you you
say right I am not trying to make money
in the short term I'm investing for the
next 20 30 40 maybe my my kids will be
investing probably for the next 60 years
that's a long time and when you're in it
for that kind of length of time your CH
the chances of something going badly
wrong are significantly uh
diminished um the next thing
is we call it phone a friend um but to
be honest a financial adviser uh is is
uh the best kind of friend I suppose
financially that you you you can have
but somebody whose opinion you you trust
and and contact them when you're worried
about the markets or your portfolio
because lots of people do irrational
things with their money they they get
very excited and they buy lots of things
or they get very worried and they sell
everything that's not a good idea so
phone a friend the fifth one only focus
on what you can control you know we we
we we we make this mistake all the time
as investors but there are actually very
very few things that we do control cost
is actually one of them so focus on
those and finally keep Investments
simple cheap and automated simple cheap
and automated that's the way to go very
good so those are some pretty um
concrete uh ideas about what we can do
but but Lucy what are the key factors to
consider when we're coming at money and
finances from a psychological
perspective because we know we're just
not logical beings you know we can hear
these great these are the six simple
steps we need to follow but but what
happens from a psychological perspective
well my argument would be that actually
the the psychology is the more logical
bit but that's because you need to
understand your relationship to money
and your relationship for risk for
example or your fear of loss and that's
so logical when you understand what
people have gone through so perhaps
somebody grew up in quite straighten
circumstances and they've got you know
fantastic opportunities for wealth now
but deep inside there's still that
five-year-old child that remembers
something quite significant like having
clothes handed down to them or
conversations that they could pick up
when they were younger around parents
talking about money and finances and
children don't necessarily understand
everything they're hearing but they can
for sure pick up the tenor of the
environment and therefore one's
childhood experiences will really really
color how you feel even as a grown-up
even when your circumstances as a
grown-up are radically different to what
they might have been uh in the early
days so I think it's crucially important
to understand why you have the views
about money that you do do you do you
always think that something will turn up
or do you always imagine that you will
always have a lack and you can change
that you know the mind is an incredibly
powerful thing mindset is everything in
life and if you go through life thinking
oh everything's going to be bad it's all
going to go wrong I'm going to be left
destitute well that's probably what's
going to manifest in your life because
you're going to go into the world with
that uh sort of Aura around you putting
out that energy and you can change that
you can definitely be the kind of person
that makes your own luck that attracts
abundance that attracts things happening
that that really build on themselves and
amplify to a positive degree but you
have to know yourself really well to
make good choices for yourself in life
whatever that is whether that's
romantically whether that's about your
career or whether it's about your
finances you have to know yourself well
enough so Robin's key rules are
fantastic and there I am scribbling them
down but I also know that some of them
will bump up against my very real fears
that you know are things that I work on
to process and I'm sure all your
listeners will have similar things where
it's like yeah I I know what my head
should be telling me uh but my heart is
saying something slightly different and
that's why I loved it when Robin said
you know phone a friend uh because
talking about these things whether it's
to someone trained in a professional
capacity like me or whether it's uh as
you say Robin someone that you trust
someone who's advice you think is sound
uh that's all all really
important but again those people are
also bringing their own psychology to
things uh they're bringing their own
life experiences so always temper the
conversations that you have with people
no matter how much you love them and
trust them with your own experiences
your own gut feel about what is really
important and healthy for you uh because
you only have one life and it's down to
the choices that you make that are the
most important thing they and other
people can't live your life for you
ultimately you then have to be the one
that makes that decision yeah so we
we've gone right to the to the heart of
the matter there Robin you write in the
book about the complicated feelings that
can be attached to managing money um be
it guilt worry blind panic um what would
your advice be to someone struggling
with those feelings well I mean Lucy is
quite right I mean behavior um plays a
hugely important part in in investing
this whole new academic discipline
called behavioral Finance which has uh
grown up over the last uh over the last
sort of 20 years or so and it's really
really fascinating and I would encourage
people who you know want to find out
more about it to to to read it because
it's it's it's well a it's fascinating
but also it's really useful and you can
apply it to your own life um I think
what I would really encourage people to
do is to actually go back to basics and
work out that the relationship between
uh money and and what a a sort of happy
contented fulfilled life looks like um
money is only a a means to an end um you
know it's not an end in itself and
um a really important starting point is
to work out you know what is important
to you um for me money is all about
helping us to live authentic lives I was
interested to hear Lucy talk about her
experiences as an investment banker she
she felt that um you know she she wasn't
in a sense living her her sort of true
life if you like and I went through
exactly the same as a as a as a TV
reporter um about sort of 15 years ago
and that um made me make some important
life changes but that's a really
important thing that people need to to
to to think about um the evidence is
actually quite mixed on whether money
can buy happiness
um to to an extent it can and there's
research that shows if you spend money
on certain things for example getting
people to do chores that you don't like
whether that's sort of cleaning or or
whatever that that is cleaning your
house that that is actually a good way
to spend money spending on experiences
generally brings us more happiness than
than stuff but ultimately you know money
is not the be all and end all Financial
well-being is just one contributor to
overall well-being you know it it needs
um to be put in its place it's important
but it's not all important although I
would just have one thing to say to that
I I agree with absolutely everything
Robin has said and there is a and at the
same time a complicating Factor
certainly in Freudian terms in the sense
that Freud would argue
that Financial supplies represent
emotional supplies which is why people
do get very hung up on the external
validation of how much am I earning how
much am I worth how big is my bank
balance how big is my car how big is my
handbag that actually we can get caught
up in the idea that ah if I if I'm worth
this much financially then this means
I'm worth this much uh as a person and
again that does have its roots in
childhood and it often has its roots in
terms of um Family Dynamics who's got
more pocket money uh who inherits more
you know that the the the the dramas in
families of the idea that you know you
have two children but the but when the
parents die the will isn't divided
equally is just there are so many
examples
where human relationships are being
played out beyond the grave as uh in
terms of monetary supplies and therefore
sometimes it is it when you're
reflecting on Robin's brilliant six
points of things to think about
investing I think it's worth paying
attention to okay how' how do I see
money what what does it symbolize for me
does it symbolize uh my value which of
course is is actually an error a false a
false uh belief really or is it about
yeah opportunity what what can I do with
this do I want to give it all away do I
want to go bungee jumping in of Victoria
Falls or you know do I what what does
that money enable me to have does it is
it freedom is it uh lack of
anxiety that sense that I can give it to
other people uh so ju again what is my
relationship to money because as Robin
said it isn't actually the money bit
that's the most important bit it's
actually
how we view it and what our relationship
to it that really counts Robin you've
also talked a lot about the costs
associated with sort of active investing
the unlikeliness of investment managers
to outperform the markets over time and
this is something that we're we're we're
always talking to our clients about at
wree um in your experience why are
people often so so blind to the costs
associated with their Investments over
time well I I absolutely agree with with
with W that that the the evidence is
just completely overwhelming not just
the academic evidence but um Regular
data produced by the likes of S&P Dow
Jones indices and Morning Star it
consistently shows that the vast
majority of active fund managers fail to
outperform the market on a properly cost
and risk adjusted basis over the long
run and the academic consensus is that
somewhere around 1% that's just a very
very tiny proportion of FS actually do
outperform genuinely outperform in the
long term and the key is how are you
going to find those uh um outperformers
in advance we can all see who they've
been with the in the past with the
benefit of hindsight but who who are the
winners going to be in the future nobody
knows um the one thing that we can
control I talked earlier about the
importance of focusing on what you can
control the one thing you can control is
cost um and you've got to see
Investments like as as being unlike any
other purchase we make if you think
about a house or a car or holiday
generally speaking the more we pay the
better it is the better the product or
service we receive in investing it's
it's completely the opposite way around
you know the less we pay in fees and
charges to have our money managed if you
like the more we keep for ourselves and
the better our uh eventual outcomes are
likely to be why does this happen well I
mean Lucy probably be able to tell you
better than I can but it's it's down to
various behavioral biases we have it's
it's um it's down to for example fomo
you know uh fear of missing out uh on on
you know a star fund manager who you
know whose performance looks great today
but you know we've seen so many of these
managers haven't we NE Woodford classic
example but there have been many many
others you know today's hero is tomorrow
zero um but the media and the active
fund industry they know just the right
buttons to press to make us invest with
these expensive funds and it's a really
bad idea Lucy do you have anything that
comes to mind when when we're having
that
conversation yeah it's absolutely right
this there is so much research whether
it's you know blind tasting wines you
think it's a really amazing wine because
you've been told that the bottle is
super expensive but in fact in terms of
your palette you probably prefer the
supermarket one just as much if it was
done in a blind tasting uh that again it
goes back to that idea of if it's
expensive it must be better that if it's
cost more in financial terms that it
must be a better whatever it is and and
you see this in dating you know the
research shows that men on dating apps
lie about their height and about their
worth their financial worth how much
they earn or how much their bank balance
is um whereas actually for women it's
their age and their weight but that's
whole other
podcast but if you
if that is literally what's still
happening in 2023 in the dating World it
just speaks to how alert our antenna is
to issues around Financial value and if
we could just strip that away and think
so much more about not just the costs
but also the relationship you know what
am I getting in terms of advice what am
I getting in terms of value added
feeling that this financial advisor is
on my side supporting me through this
you know journey of of financial growth
those are going to be way more valuable
in the long term than than just pure
costs we've been doing some research at
wry specifically around property and
mortgages actually and I I've got some
specific questions for both of you but
just to kick us off Robin what's your
assessment of the health of the property
Market current here in the UK well as uh
what I call an evidence-based investor
one of the key um no knows of
evidence-based investing is making
Market predictions I I I don't make
Market predictions and look I've been
wrong on the property market for about
the last 30
years uh you know I was
expecting a fall uh a significant fall
in in in prices by now it just hasn't
happened why
I think it's largely down to supply
reasons of lack of Supply um and of
course that might change if if say a new
government comes in and and possibly
buils lots more houses that that that
might change it wouldn't surprise me to
see prices come down substantially or to
see the kind of situation that's
happened in Japan where where where
prices were just um steady for for for
decades um uh what I would just say to
people about houses is do they actually
need more than one house um you know you
are already quite exposed to uh the risk
of the housing market just by owning
your own home so if you own say two
three or 10 homes then you are
magnifying that risk and yes it has
worked over the last sort of 20 years or
so but will it work over the next 20
years is I don't know the other thing is
do you need such a big house you know um
you know it doesn't seem long ago that
my wife and I are having conversations
about moving to a bigger house but now
we've reached an age where actually this
is more than sufficient for what we want
uh that's another really key thing the
only other thing I would say is remember
the hassle factor in buying a house um
if you buy an index fund or a a lowcost
index portfolio you know they're not
going to phone you up on a Saturday
night to tell you that the boiler's
packed up um you know it's it's simple
it's a simple investment that's not
going to cause you lots of hassle um we
underestimate the costs involved in
maintaining a house but also the the
emotional costs and the time
costs Lucy do you think it's even
possible to be
analytical um in this way when it comes
to something as emotionally charged as
home
ownership well I think you do have to be
analytical I mean the office for
National statistics announced today that
house prices have fallen by by by only
0.1% and that's despite all of the
mortgage rate increases that occurred in
the summer uh which I I think Robin's
right I think it's basically down to
housing stock you know and the lack of
uh Supply but your home is where you
live so it isn't just about and this is
actually a slightly peculiar British
thing because there are lots of
countries in the world where home
ownership doesn't have the same Allure
but certainly in a country like uh
Britain it's very much about having an
asset in addition to it being about
where you live and there is a lot made
of house prices because there is that
there has been that expectation over the
last 20 to 30 years maybe longer which
is that you will buy at X but you will
be able to sell at Y and that doesn't
always happen in other countries around
the world there's just an expectation I
buy at X I don't pay any rent uh and and
then maybe I have it as an asset to to
give to my kids but it's just it's
somewhere where I live whereas in
Britain it's it's it has been combined
with this idea of something that will
make you a ton of money at the end of it
um although obviously any of the US who
are old enough to remember the days of
negative equity would would remind you
that that doesn't you know what can what
can go up can also go down but I think
certainly in terms of your attachment to
your home it and and this is why I I
think a lot of people look at people who
buy other properties to do them up and
sell them very quickly are often quite
curious because many of us you you buy
your home and you just don't want to
leave it it's it's it has all of your
emotional longings and your experiences
and that's a very beautiful part of your
life and why would you want to willingly
give that up so I think the idea that
you can treat it just as a commodity is
is quite hard because for many people
it's as Robin hinted you know it's where
you raise your children it's where maybe
you were carried over the threshold by
your spouse where you had incredible
experiences maybe you did up the garden
maybe you decorated it's it's got so
much of us in that it it becomes almost
like an extension of the family people
are very used to the idea that your pet
is an extension of your family but I
often feel that your home is is part of
that it it represents that container of
safety that you've created for yourself
and when Robin says you know it's quite
emotional to to let go of a house to
sell a house I think that's right that's
why ultimately it can be so difficult uh
when you come to downsize because you
just don't want to let that part of
your current life or your past go I
think also because interest rates have
been low for some time I suppose the T
the tendency has been for people
especially firsttime buyers to take the
most amount of debt that they possibly
could and therefore you know get the the
biggest mortgage and I guess now with
interest rates changing perhaps our
attitude to debt and our attitude to to
home ownersh ship will will change again
too I think that's inevitable uh Harriet
um I I I mean I certainly hope it
happens um I mean I think you have to
distinguish between good debt and bad
debt and and and there are there
are types of debt that are better than
others and and are effectively good
debts um you know um investing in
education is is is is is really
important
yes going to college is fish expensive
but but actually that is an example of a
of a good debt to have generally
speaking it's not for everyone uh but
but it is the right decision for for for
many people um having a mortgage
generally is a good debt a good debt to
have it you know we we we get as as Lucy
says benefits uh
over and above the
financial from from from from owning a
home um you know and maybe you know this
era of higher interest rates will make
us sort of start to see houses as as
homes rather than rather than the
Investments that that that uh that they
become um but um yeah let let's stop um
uh giving in to this um constant uh
advertising which gets us to to buy now
and pay later um you know I was watching
excellent Martin Lewis um program the
the the the other day and and and him
saying how you know that is just a
really really bad habit to get into um
if you can clear your credit card every
month and if you can just resist buying
something if you can't actually pay for
it now generally speaking that will you
know stand you in very very good stead
financially for the future I I want to
conclude by asking you both about
relationships and money as so much of
our work at wre is focused on trying to
get the whole family around the table uh
when it comes to conversations about
wealth so Robin how do you recommend
couples approach their investments from
a practical
perspective well talk you know to talk
about money and and and not just about
investing uh you know what do you want
to achieve basically have honest open
conversations and by the way especially
before you get married um uh but ongoing
um you know share those responsibilities
you know so many couples it's the man
who makes the investment decisions that
is a bad idea know it has been shown
that although women are generally more
cautious than men and often when they
tend to uh put too much money in cash
and not enough money in shares they're
not as prone to overconfidence and
overtrading as men are and actually
um the evidence shows that that women
actually do achieve slightly better
returns than men as a result so so so
involve the you know both parties if you
like in that in that
conversation Lucy for managing
Investments together do you have any
advice for how to navigate potential
conflicts that could arise I don't know
differences in risk tolerance as Robin
alluded to there or or potentially even
the goals well I think Robin is
absolutely right it is about
communication and conversations but that
would obviously also include listening
you have to listen to your partner to
hear what their appetite for risk is or
to hear what their fears are because uh
and I don't know whether you're going to
bleep this out but you know there is
quite there is that difference between
the genders in a very sort of
heteronormative way you know you've got
the Willy waving of the men and you've
got a slightly more interior perspective
from the women and and therefore
sometimes that can actually be the
complimentarity of that can work really
beautifully as it would you know during
sex that actually you know the meant to
come together so you can if you can have
a great conversation together and say
well maybe you take a little bit of
extra risk in that um part of the
portfolio but I'm going to be a little
bit more risk averse in this one but
together our overall risk profile will
be you know whatever it is 70 or 80%
then that would be better I
think this might be too late for some
people listening to this podcast but
yeah have those conversations before you
finalize your union because what some of
us do with with our clients is we get
them to draw up a value list you know
what what are your top 10 values and
then you ask your partner to do what are
their top 10 values and obviously
ideally your your 10 values match their
10 values that you both think that
Fidelity is really important and that uh
you know sense of humor is really
important and attitude to money and risk
is is the same but if you find that your
um need for Fidelity or or attitude to
risking money is up here number 10 but
for them it's not right down here at the
bottom then that's going to tell do
something about uh future issues for
navigation going forward uh but in all
seriousness I think it is just about
having those ongoing conversations
because again if you're I was doing some
uh research recently for um for Ashley
Madison the married dating website
people and we were looking at the fact
that you know people could live to 120
quite soon and if you're going to be
having a shared relationship with
someone from the age of let's say 30 or
35 everything around your life will
change and that includes your attitude
to money that includes what your needs
will be your needs in your 30s around
money are very very different and whiter
are brilliant at kind
of uh flexing this when they're talking
to their clients okay what's your life
and your demands in your 30s and your
40s but actually hang on what's it going
to be like in your 70s when you're 90
are you going to have to Pivot to think
more about you know living health care
or funding for for a care home then you
you would never really have to think
about that in in your 30s hopefully so
even that demands that your
conversations with your partner need to
be ongoing uh for the rest of your life
but but also make it fun because money
money doesn't have to be
about anxiety and concern it can be
about playfulness and and the joy that
it brings your life and as Robin said so
early on in in this conversation it's
about the potential what what kind of
life does it enable you to lead and
that's you only have one life so make
sure you squeeze the most out of
it that's a wonderful way to to end so
Robin Lucy thank you so much and if any
of the issues we've discussed in today's
episode Peak your interest please visit
y- tree.com to find out more about wree
and the work we're doing to provide an
alternative perspective on money and
life and if you liked what you heard
please subscribe to the podcast so you
don't miss an episode and feel free to
explore our back catalog of content if
you want to learn more about money and
life